und die hat mir dann meine mutter
gekauft und in der schule haben alle
gesagt ich sehe aus wie ein clown so
leute dass es dieses schöne ausführt wir
haben hier black fashion kannst du es
noch hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video jahre alte ich hab
natürlich euch bin zurück ganz schnell
bevor das wieder losgeht ich freue mich
sehr darüber
endlich ist mein wirklich eigener
workshop online das ganze heißt einfach
alex i punkt shop also ohne punkte oder
punkt kommen dahinter ist einfach alex
wie punkt shop eingeben ist natürlich
auch in der video beschreibung verlinkt
und kommt dann auf dem shop ich hatte
jetzt in der vergangenheit schon mal auf
unterschiedlichen seiten mal so sachen
von mir allerdings jetzt schon sehr sehr
lange nichts neues mehr gekommen und
jetzt ist ein neues teil draußen an dem
wir wirklich sehr lange gesessen haben
bis wir komplett zufrieden waren ich
habe das auch und ich würde es natürlich
sehr freuen wenn ich demnächst einige
von euch in der stadt rumlaufen sehen
würde mit diesem hobby so leute noch mal
ganz schnell hier der hohe im
schnelldurchlauf wir haben hier wie das
könnte ich natürlich für alex ii stehen
kann aber auch für alles mögliche andere
stehen dann steht auf den seiten no
games plate in gelb und hinten haben wir
die schule muss also suchen die das auf
100% baumwolle kostet neun euro gibt s m
l xl für jeden was dabei und viel spaß
dabei beim vielleicht einkaufen
davon würde mich freuen gut werbung
gemacht ich habe mir passend zu diesem
thema heute auch was überlegt und zwar
wenn ich gerade bei meinen eltern und
ich habe letztens mal so ein paar
klamotten von mir aus einem
kleiderschrank rausgeschmissen weil ich
die einfach nicht mehr anziehen und mir
ist dabei aufgefallen dass ich echt doch
viele sachen drin hatte auch so von vor
vier fünf jahren falls du sachen die ich
mir damals mal gekauft habe wo ich noch
nicht wirklich auf meinen kleidungsstil
geachtet haben beziehungsweise hat
geschaut habe was zusammen passt und was
nicht und deswegen geht es heute um mein
kleidungsstil als 15-jähriger ja ich
will zu sagen 15 16
ich habe ein paar klamotten rausgesucht
wohl schon zum teil gar nicht mehr
wusste dass ich das überhaupt noch habe
vor vier jahren war es nämlich noch
überhaupt nicht normal dass man sneaker
von nike dreh oder rudi von adidas oder
so also ich bin zu der zeit eigentlich
eher schlicht rumgelaufen oder hatte mal
irgendwas von jack johnson oder superdry
oder so ich weiß ja wo ich das was sagt
ja werken nicht superdry wir sind ja
heute auch ziemlich in auf jeden fall
sind die sachen bei wo ich also die
würde ich heutzutage halt wirklich auf
kleinsten mehr anziehen und bei uns auf
der schule damals lieber eigentlich
jeder so ich war eigentlich der erste
denn einmal sony kann hatte von von nike
oder so da wird man dann vor 45 jahren
auch wirklich komisch für angeguckt wenn
man da plötzlich so halt diese sneaker
die heutzutage eigentlich jeder an hut
getragen hat wo alle anderen aber noch
irgendwelche schlichten schwarzen schuhe
arten von der marke keine ahnung geox
oder so fragt mich jetzt nicht das war
dann auch so die zeit wo langsam dieses
obey und so kam der aus der zeit sind
diese ganzen klamotten die ich hier rum
fliegen habt ich will gar nicht lange
lagern ich zeige euch die gerne was ich
aber noch sagen wollte wenn ihr auch mal
lust habe dass ich euch klamotten zeigen
wo ich so 7 war weil ich hab ich auch
noch gefunden dann geht man noch nach
oben dann sehe ich das für eventuell
noch ein paar sowie fangen jetzt aber an
und zwar mit einem t shirt ich werde
euch dass wir hier auch mal zeigen wenn
ich es an hab also ich wie das dann
draußen aussieht wenn wir die sachen
überhaupt noch passen ich bin jetzt
nicht mehr so krass gewachsen glaube ich
habe ein bisschen schon und zwar dieses
t shirt von was ist das hier vorne steht
so hey drauf das war auf jeden fall für
die damalige zeit was schon relativ
auffälliges ja also dass wir jetzt das
erste t shirt erwarte ich jetzt auch
wirklich nicht so viel ich habe ja schon
gesagt ich bin damals eher schlicht
rumgelaufen und so machen wie dieses
city gab es doch nicht oder gab es halt
vielleicht aber die waren gar nicht so
hat in der jugend als nächstes ich
glaube auf dieses shirt war sogar
ziemlich stolz das habe ich damals schon
bei snipes gekauft vielleicht kennt das
auch noch der ein oder andere von euch
und zwar steht da drauf fakt ist und ich
saß dann wirklich so ab und zu in der
schule vom lehrer und hatte so ein shirt
an diese frau drauf war dem lehrer den
mittelfinger gezeigt hat und runter
stand [ __ ] it mit 15
ich weiß auch nicht wieso aber irgendwie
hab ich mir da gar nichts bei gedacht
was zu der zeit also wir reden hier so
von 2000 2014 2013/2014 genau was da
total in war da liefen alle jungs mit
sehr engen hosen herum also diese zeit
mit diesen etwas weiteren hosen war
vorbei und ich habe mir dann als erstes
mal diese skinny jeans geholt von
die ist von h&m genau von h&m die hose
ich sie gerne an für euch aber die ist
so eng und ich bin damit wirklich
herumgelaufen ist natürlich jetzt noch
enger als früher
ja ich zeige euch das mal kurz in
kombination mit dem fakt shirt viel spaß
solche erstes outfit wir haben hier das
wunderschöne [ __ ] it was möchte ich noch
ziemlich gut und diese skinny jeans die
ist halt echt extrem eng aber ich habe
auch gedacht dass sie mir noch
schlechter passt also es geht noch
kollegen wenn du damit konnten der
schule sitzen ja habe ich schon gesagt
also wir machen weiter mit einem pulli
den ich glaube ich sogar schon den habe
ich mit vierzehn glaube ich auch schon
getragen und zwar sieht ja eigentlich
auch ganz gut aus ist in diesem grünen
ton
das war so eine ahnung das ist
eigentlich so ein standard pulli den man
so in der neunten klasse hatte und was
mich jetzt extrem 100 hier steht dass
der in xl sein soll schaut euch mal an
das dsl und das ist echt schon relativ
was heißt für mich und der hier wäre
meiner meinung nach alle allerhöchstens
also ich selbst überhaupt nicht ich
ziehe das vielleicht natürlich auch mal
an und ihr könnt auch sehr gerne mal in
die kommentare schreiben was ihr dazu
sagt so das ist der polit übrigens mit
aufgefallen das ist zwar excel aber das
ist kinder größe xl also hat natürlich
nichts mit excel zu tun sieht man auch
würde ich heutzutage niemals mittragen
wenn mein bruder bestimmen oder bisschen
haben schenke ich dir ganz ehrlich nicht
okay bekommen zunächst ein t shirt leute
haltet euch wirklich fest wenn ich jetzt
daran denke dass ich so umgelaufen binde
das ist ganz schlimm
und zwar kanada dieser 2014 war glaube
ich dieses black fashion ja da war black
fashion total ja und so was habe ich da
auch extrem gefeiert auf das war ich
auch sehr stolz das war dann auch so die
zeit wo ich zum ersten mal in discos
gegangen bin halt mit 16
und da habe ich sehr oft gerne dieses
shirt angezogen in kombination mit einer
skinny jeans die aus alpiner leggins und
moment wird gelacht mich jetzt echt
nicht auch ist das schön
leute geht auf jeden fall in den shop
alex wie punkt job ganz wichtig er diese
show habe ich mit 15 jahren gekauft und
zwar bei einem laden hier aus meiner
kleinen stadt da würde ich heutzutage
niemals mehr auch nur einen schritt rein
wagen
was will man dazu sagen die wurden mir
an gedreht weil die frau gesagt hat die
sind super cool damit kann man alles
tragen damit kann man alles kombinieren
und die hat mir dann meine mutter
gekauft und in der schule haben alle
gesagt ich sehe aus wie ein clown ist ja
auch verständlich und das weiß ich auch
noch diese schuhe hatte ich dann einmal
wirklich mit 16 jahren im club an das
outfit kann ich euch mal ungefähr
zusammen basteln und zwar sah das so aus
also leute dass es dieses schöne outfit
wir haben hier black fashion kennst du
es noch dann nochmal diese wunderschöne
hose und schaut euch diese schuhe an
hier findest du dich nur gehen ja david
fahren ständig dir und das war mein
erstes disco outfit
ja da muss man sich schon recht belasten
fehlen ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben wie es findet ich
bin es immer noch echt scheiße
das war allerdings der einmalige sache
die show habe ich glaube ich danach nie
wieder angezogen und die wurden dann
beim nächsten discobesuch glaube ich
durch airforce er selbst allerdings
nicht diese weißen die ja eigentlich
jeder kennen sondern das waren so grau
ich glaube gab es noch vor den weißen
ich habe die leider nicht mehr also die
wurden irgendwann mal im
altkleidercontainer abgegeben was
natürlich auch völlig normal ist und
cool was ja auch eigentlich das einzig
richtige ist also wenn ihr irgendwas
nicht mehr tragbar ist nicht mehr schön
und gibt es bestimmt auch eine menge
leute die ich trotzdem gerne haben
würden so jetzt habt ihr gehört mein
klub outfit gesehen wir machen weiter
und zwar kann ich euch sofort eine
nächste woche zeigen die ich von allen
sachen hier noch am besten finde mit dem
grünen rudi da und zwar ist dass diese
ebenfalls skinny jeans von habe ich auch
bei h&m gekauft ich arbeite hosen habe
ungefähr 30 euro gekostet das weiß ich
noch weil ich damals immer so mit 100
euro shoppen gehen durfte und habe mir
dann halt diese rosen gekauft so was
auch bei obwohl wenn man ich sag mal so
wenn man dazu den weißen rudi anzieht
oder ein weißes shirt könnte ich das
sogar heutzutage noch anziehen und zwar
solche shorts von ihm keine ahnung
ebenfalls sauer denn ich glaube alles
war damals von h&m
ja die habe ich auch noch gefunden so
leute und zum schluss haben wir noch
diese wunderschöne rose natürlich auch
echt trendy und fashion am besten sind
diese schlappen ich bedanke mich sehr
für eure aufmerksamkeit und wünsche euch
noch einen angenehmen abend also schaut
dass wir nur noch zum ende so leute das
hier kann ich mich auch noch daran
erinnern das ist ein typischer pulli den
halt denke ich mal meine mutter damals
gekauft hat und ja ich war froh dass ich
nicht selber einkaufen gehen musste oder
es kann auch sein dass ich mir dann
schon selber gekauft habe ebenfalls von
h&m konnte man hier oben hat so schön zu
ziehen und das gleiche gab es dann auch
noch etwas dunkler von broadway wobei
ich den eigentlich gar nicht schlimm
findet den könnte ich heutzutage auch
noch problemlos anziehen genau also die
schlimmsten sachen hatten wir es auf
jeden fall schon das schlimmste ist
natürlich mit abstand dieses black
fashion dingen schaut gerne eure meinung
in die kommentare
und hier habe ich noch was gefunden das
hatte ich auch damals sehr gerne an zwar
war das ein bisschen schicker konnte man
auch mal in die schule anziehen wobei
ich mir dann auch denke wenn ich
manchmal in die schule gegangen bin mit
diesem paket t shirt und am nächsten tag
da saß in seinem dunkelroten feinem
swatch haben sich die lehrer
wahrscheinlich auch gedacht was hat der
junge davor da in der letzten reihe der
die ganze zeit mit seinem nachbarn
komischen kleidungsstil gut
mehr habe ich leider nicht mehr gefunden
wobei ich mich noch an viele viele
sachen erinnern kann dich aber leider
nicht mehr habe das waren jetzt die
letzten sachen die ich noch über hatte
die ich wirklich nie nie nie nie nie
wieder mehr anziehen würde
einfach weil es gar nicht mehr beim stil
entspricht ich finds echt krass ich
glaube ich würde mich total anders
kleiden und überhaupt nicht so
selbstbewusst wenn ich keine news über
geworden wäre das hört sich vielleicht
dumm an aber dadurch dass ich so viele
freunde habt die influenza sind youtuber
was weiß ich bekommt man irgendwie immer
die neuesten trends automatisch mit ja
also ich glaube werde ich nehme youtube
so wirklich in berührung gekommen oder
mit diesem ganzen instagram zeug dann
würde ich heute wirklich noch rumlaufen
wie damals natürlich wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen mehr an herren style angelehnt
na wie heißt das noch mal ein bisschen
besser aufeinander abgestimmt aber ich
glaube sie ist hätte ich auf keinen fall
glaube ich würde ungelogen auch so leute
dann berechnen die so wie sie es an
hätten
so da total teure klamotten tragen was
ich zum teil auch irgendwie jetzt tue
das nicht eigentlich für 500 euro zu
kaufen
aber gut das ist etwas anderes ich hoffe
dass wieder hat euch gefallen wie schon
gesagt wenn ihr mal bock habt dass ich
meine outfits präsentieren wo ich so 7
war oder vielleicht auch noch länger ich
weiß es nicht natürlich kann ich ja
nicht mehr tragen aber ich kann euch die
klamotten zeigen lassen da nach oben da
wir sehen uns vermutlich morgen oder
übermorgen wieder ich wünsche euch noch
einen schönen tag vergesst auf keinen
fall den shop abzuchecken erster link in
der beschreibung könnt euch gerne ein
pulli kostet 39 euro und ist wirklich
super qualität aus portugal statt
gangstar west ab wir sehen uns herein